the thing that really like goes sideways
is how could you look at this guy and
not think he's on juice right like hang
on where's the picture
this like this is him over here let's go
a little bit bigger
like I don't know how anybody could look
at that and be like oh that's that's
that's completely natural he he got that
way from eating beef balls and setting
his nuts and um
grounding and Sun like you know getting
sun on his skin and not wearing a shirt
and growing a hair in his beard and all
that sort of stuff like that's how he
got to that and by the way he's he's in
his 40s I think he's 44 45 he's in his
mid-4 mid-ish 40s
um
I knew right away
when
somebody asked me on a podcast like
months ago maybe even like a year ago
they're like what do you think a liver
King and I didn't even know who the [ __ ]
he was I did I'd Google him and I looked
up a picture I'm like oh this guy's on
gear for sure the dead giveaway is the
apps okay if you have a distended belly
because when you're on steroids
especially things like Deca and like
these aren't bioidentical you know
compounds like these are all
they're not okay you could be on other
[ __ ] too the [ __ ] knows but it wasn't in
the email but like your muscles grow
when you stress them and then you feed
them and you repair and you sleep and
you feed them and you repair and you
sleep and you stress them they'll you
know the muscles will grow but as a
consequence of that your internal organs
and all the tissue around your organs
some like all the sub subcutaneous
tissue that's between the muscle around
the organs the organs themselves they
also respond to androgens as well and
they often grow and they enlarge
um you know one of the consequences of
using too much gear is you can have an
enlarged heart it's one of the problems
that a lot of bodybuilders have which is
why they don't live very [ __ ] long
which you know it's it's it's generally
for like short-lived career for most
bodybuilders like Rich Piana was a
perfect example of that he was jacked
and juicy as hell and I think he died in
his early 40s he had a heart attack I
think his girlfriend was cutting his
hair if I'm not mistaken was a story God
do look phenomenal but there's
consequences for putting that much crap
in your body like look again therapeutic
testosterone is different from running
bodybuilding sort of stacks therapeutic
testosterone gets you back to levels
that you're at when you're in your 25 30
like in and around there you know is
what you aim for like that's what I aim
for I want upper high range so you can
take a look at your ranges when you do
your blood Labs I have my right at the
upper high range and people go like you
know well where do you have it at it's
like there that's where I have it well
like you know how do you get it there
you just turn up you just inject a
little bit more too high you don't
inject you know so much when you do your
blood Labs so you monitor those things
but doctors because their medical
license
and their practice is at risk don't do
anything to put your health into danger
zone right they're monitoring your uh
prostate your your PSA they're
monitoring your blood lipids your
cholesterols your organ Health your
Kidney Health like kidneys are usually
the first thing that go when it comes to
steroid abuse like body like looking
like this that's usually the first thing
to go now from what I understand
somebody's got copies of his blood Labs
out there you probably see a video maybe
uh maybe the delt King you know we'll be
putting it out in the next couple of
days Derek
um because apparently that information
has also become available and I would
guarantee you that when you see those
blood Labs they're probably going to be
[ __ ]
um for you to take that amount of gear
and eat that much protein that that much
meat if that's in fact what he was
eating like I don't know if he did it
every day if it was just for the camera
for like a you know for like a a show
um your blood panels are not going to be
good I mean we'll wait and see when that
comes out but I'm but I'm personally
interested to see you know what he got
out of that another dead giveaway by the
way is the size of the veins
okay
um when you're when you're taking
bodybuilder dosages of steroids your
veins pop big time like that and they
enlarge as well uh your blood pressure
generally goes up your hemoglobin your
hematocrit you know leans into dangerous
areas which all that means is your blood
gets thicker right because you have you
have
um
I'm gonna completely [ __ ] [ __ ] it up
because I'm not a Bro Science Guy but
basically you're making more red blood
cells to move oxygen around
and as a consequence of that your your
blood itself gets thicker so
um I mean like even guys on therapeutic
dosages of of testosterone usually
generally have to either donate blood or
they have to monitor it closely
um one of the things I do about once a
month because I go in for a vitamin bag
over my doctor's office
um and once a month you know the bag's
empty vitamin bag is done in you wait a
little bit they throw the bag on the
ground and then you just drain out a
little bit of blood to make sure that
your hemoglobin and your hematocrits in
safe territory mine usually rides right
at the upper limit so I usually bring it
down you know a little bit by doing a
little bit of a bleed out it's called a
therapeutic phlebotomy I always
pronounce that wrong but that's what it
is that's what the process is but I
think guys like this when you see veins
that big like my veins never get that
big that's just [ __ ] ridiculous
um that is a lot and
the problem that I have with all of that
is look dude you know maybe you're you
know desecrated beef and heart and liver
supplements were all good and useful and
they're they're quality products but the
only reason why you were selling a
hundred [ __ ] million dollars a year
of this [ __ ] maybe it's not ship I'm
just calling it [ __ ] but the only reason
why you're selling that much of it is
because you went around with your goofy
hat on
this this guy over here
these stupid [ __ ] hat on
telling telling people to eat raw liver
and then doing podcast shows dude never
wore a shirt like he like he was the
brand right like like liver he didn't
even call himself Brian Johnson anymore
he actually started to refer to himself
in the third person
uh and just said you know liver King
like liver King actually ate Brian
Johnson I think there was something like
that that came up at some point right so
like there's nothing on here of him even
wearing a shirt anywhere with the
exception of this one over here which is
a recent one and even snowboarding here
in this indoor ski hill which I'm
guessing is in Saudi Arabia or Dubai or
something like that he's not even
wearing a shirt but his entire brand was
you know look jacked and juicy as hell
and then go on podcasts and then when
people ask you if you were on gear you
would just deny it which you did
routinely over and over again and I'll
be honest with you a lot of these
podcasts that he was on he was on a lot
of um Fitness and Nutrition podcasts and
I don't think that they cornered him
hard enough I don't think they
you know we're serious about getting to
the bottom of it or calling him out it
was just because oh he has a social
media following cool let's put him on
our on our podcast and we'll talk and
he's very clever about talking about his
uh products like I watched
I watched one entire podcast either with
graham Stefan okay and if you don't know
who Graham Stefan he's got a pretty
popular Channel he's a little dude by
the way liver King is short as [ __ ] I
can tell right away because when he was
sitting at the table with Graham and I
look at him right now and I look at his
limb lengths like I think Graham's about
five five six he looks identical in limb
length and stature uh to my old um
roommate back in my 20s I used to call
him pocket Hercules he was Jack Dude too
but he was pure natural he was about 155
pounds and I heard somewhere in the
podcast that he that he claims liver can
claims that he weighs 195 200 pounds
which is like 50 pounds more muscle than
what my buddy weighed and anyway so
that's a lot for a guy that size that's
going to put a lot of stress on his
organs a lot of stress on his body
um you keep doing that over a prolonged
period of time you're knocking you're
not even knocking days or hours off your
life you're locking you're basically
knocking years off your life I don't
know what the equation would be maybe
for every five years that he's you know
looking like this like as jacked as this
he could potentially be knocking off a
year you know
of his life maybe it's a year for every
10 years who the [ __ ] knows but
depending on whether or not he's
managing his blood levels which I mean
like you think like he would be you know
with the kind of money that he's got you
know selling a hundred thousand dollars
using [ __ ] supplements like you'd
think he would be and there's guys like
the rock out there that just look
[ __ ] ridiculous like the rock is 50.
Michael Hearn I think is 52. I'm gonna
get into those guys in a little bit they
just look [ __ ] ridiculous and there's
absolutely no way that that's achievable
achievable naturally but they also
always deny it so he's not the first guy
to do it he's not the last guy to do it
no a couple things as well too
um
yeah there's somebody here in the
comments saying roid's mess with
people's heads
um
probably at the doses that he's doing he
might have a shorter fuse but in the
interviews that I watched him in he
seemed fairly composed he's he's well
spoken he's thought out he has a team
with him everywhere he goes like he even
travels with his weights you know he
travels on a [ __ ] private jet and he
brings his weights with him so that he's
always got something to work out with
you know for the show for the the social
media team that's filming his you know
his reels in his tick tocks and his
YouTubes and all that [ __ ] so he can
promote it when he's on the podcast he's
always bringing raw food with him uh Raw
Liver raw meat raw heart marrow [ __ ]
like that and then he gets the guests to
try it and then he also shows them well
you know if you don't like that then you
can have this supplement that I have in
my lineup or I also own this company and
you can get your nutrients and then he
talks about his ancestral tenants so so
like he's put together a very well
intertwined
[ __ ] of
um stories like this guy's a Storyteller
he has more stories in Walt Disney and
he's got some good stories but he's
again he is the brand the story is him
it's the shirtless dude sitting in the
chair with his goofy hat on talking
about
how he lives the nine ancestral tenants
and look like that which you don't it's
impossible there's no [ __ ] amount of
pills or uh beef blood you know protein
shakes that you can drink from his line
that is ever going to make you look like
that hey guys I really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's and in
the top comment below in this video
peace out